[Music]
[Rushing waves]
Hey it's me, Destin. We're in the Gulf
of Mexico and we're about to go fishing.
And I'm gonna beat all
these guys at fishing.
- It's not gonna happen.
- It's not gonna be me.
(Destin) Alright ladies,
how're we doing over here?
- Look at our basket and see
how we're doing over here.
- ...Caught triggerfish.
(Destin) Triggerfish?
- I caught 'im.
(Destin) You caught it?
So the reason they call it
a triggerfish is because
you have to pull a trigger in order
to get the dorsal fin to go down.
(Destin) Ah!
(Destin) Okay, if you ask me
it is awesome anytime there's
some type of mechanical
device built into an animal.
Well that's just the case
with the triggerfish.
The front dorsal fin is a
spine that locks in position.
It cannot be folded down until the
rear one is folded backwards,
just like pulling a trigger on a gun.
Now, this is good for two reasons:
The first reason is a triggerfish
likes to hide in a hole,
and it'll lock the front dorsal fin.
No predator can get it out unless
it chooses to unlock itself
Secondly, if a predator tries
to eat the triggerfish
The huge dorsal fin on the front will
rip its insides apart, killing it.
So, it's a build in defense mechanism.
[Cocking sound effect]
[Bang]
[Seagulls crying]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.